Red Dead Redemption too is shaping up to
be one of the biggest games of the year
so it makes sense you'll want to try
your hand at it even if you didn't get
around to playing the first one there's
always some concern around games that
have a 2 on the end returning players
hope for callbacks to their beloved
characters and story points while
newcomers must still be able to make
sense of things in our experience
Rockstar has done a pretty good job of
making sure everybody will have a good
time with this one whether you're
already a rootin tootin cowboy or asking
mustn her first and foremost it's
important to note that this is a prequel
and the protagonist arthur morgan is a
brand-new character to the series don't
let that worry you if you're an
old-school fan though as the game
revolves around a gang led by returning
character dutch mandolin this is the
very same gang that john marston ran
with before the events of Red Dead
Redemption 1 and also includes some
other familiar faces like Xavier Bill
Williamson uncle and Abigail for a full
rundown on the events of the first game
you can check out our story so far
feature it won't affect your enjoyment
of interacting with the gang if this is
your first introduction to them but
seeing them at a different point in
their respective lives and witnessing
the things that happen to them which
ultimately shape the people they become
in Red Dead Redemption 1 is a great
treat for fans of the series since John
Marston is a member of the gang you'll
have the opportunity to engage with him
fairly regularly and there's some
excellent Easter eggs in there for those
who played the first game including a
clue as to how John got his scar and
Arthur's delight in making fun of John's
inability to swim in terms of the game
world many parts of the map from the
first game are contained within that of
the sequel this is equally cool for fans
revisiting locations as it is for
newcomers who get to experience the
region's they would have missed out on
as the game progresses however
particularly into its later stages
players of the first game are heavily
rewarded for their prior Envy
in the series we don't want to spoil
anything so I'll leave it at that
Red Dead Redemption 2 is shaping up to
be a great cowboy adventure whether or
not you've played Red Dead Redemption 1
Rockstar plays the balancing act between
rewarding series fans and not alienating
newcomers pretty well in our experience
so far let us know if you've played the
first one and who you're excited to see
return in the long awaited follow-up for
everything else you'll want to know
about Red Dead Redemption 2 and make
sure you check out a new show quick-draw
you must be nervous being this close to
the water don't you start are you
grinding your teeth and anticipation for
Red Dead Redemption to chuck same here
we here at GameSpot are just as excited
to get our hands on rockstars next big
game so we figured we bundle up our Red
Dead video coverage into a weekly series
called a quick draw loop wrap in quick
draw we'll take a deep dive into Red
Dead - exploring gameplay mechanics
story open-world the good the bad the
ugly you name it from the sound of it
Red Dead 2 will be a vast and unique
experience for everyone playing meaning
will be sharing stories about the things
we encounter in the game for weeks to
come so tune in every Friday for quick
draw on GameSpot calm or youtube.com
slash GameSpot see yep
you
[Music]